live and direct from Hollywood it's
Thanksgiving we're gonna go check out
some of the weirdest Thanksgiving stuff
in LA which I'm really excited about
wouldn't have three things giving meals
in one day let's do this it's gonna be
awesome [ __ ] love Thanksgiving and I
brought my secret weapon it's in this
bag look at you mister suspense
Thanksgiving my family is generally very
traditional and there's a lot of
football family time friend time and
just being able like chill my parents
are immigrants from Malaysia
Thanksgiving to us it's a great time to
hang out and eat hotpot we are about to
roll up on the voice there where we're
gonna eat Thanksgiving turkey burger lay
the buns made out of stuffing oh no see
the only thing that's the only thing I
don't like what we're looking for the
coolest craziest wildest Thanksgiving
dish the burgers a month is actually the
turducken burger a lot of flavor
can I give you a hug hey but this looks
amazing thank you yeah
but reduction is three patties of meat
on top of each other duck pastrami
turkey burger chicken a chicken burger
cheers guys
Cheers it's delicious we weren't even
hit my mouth I have chills
Wow it's so well constructed the flavors
melt to each other it tastes like the
holiday season what's our rubric here
creativity I'll give it a mahat are you
kidding me turducken hen this is a nine
and holiday spirit her duck ten is what
we're talking about here from us even to
a Freddie how wild is bread here I'll
give it an eight on wild packard it was
spicy at all no I'm gonna get a seven
explain you're doing it right love it
love it love it
next up we got our good friends at
doghouse doghouse doll commercialized in
hot dog
we really hate on that no no no no no
they're great but fritters are better
come on what do you think we are here
for that yeah you're going to eat their
turducken special which has smoked tuna
canned sausage sage gravy Brussels
sprouts bacon slaw crispy onions all on
a Hawaiian roll I think I would be the
turkey because it's the biggest I'm
chicken cuz I'm the most basic here
she's the duck cuz she's smooth or she
catch a lot whoa hey oh not expect that
every Thanksgiving happy that's it don't
want wear white pants to be
yeah there's like plenty little niblets
inside the sausage look at Rizzoli Thank
You spirits the creativity here is I'm a
success I've never seen anything quite
like this a full oral experience you've
got the good read
it's like if we combine fourth of July
and Thanksgiving this is what you would
get holiday vibe five I would order this
any time of year
wild factor I get this a knife have you
ever seen a hot dog like this
no then how's another ten because I
think that there's got to be room for
growth yeah it's turducken you slow the
words are done so now we're gonna go do
Thanksgiving ice cream its salt & straw
you're gonna have to roll me home well
for real look at the stomach we just
pulled up we're gonna eat Thanksgiving
themed ice cream if it's turkey flavored
I'm gonna barf I think me into some
cranberries and sweet potato sweet
potato
it's potato it's not potatoes nobody
says oh tato
are ha ice cream maker Tyler and his
team have turned the entire Thanksgiving
table into ice creams so we've got sweet
potato with maple pecan wailing then
again sweet potato meat aisle with a
hell salted caramel ice cream made with
turkey fat instead of butter and turkey
skin that's been turned into a crispy
candy brittle no yeah you guys perhaps
have a bathroom around here oh he's
pulling out his bigger weapon yes
Stephen brought his prop Thanksgiving
pants
I'm embarrassed on your behalf how's the
sweet potato mmm
good is what Thanksgiving tastes like
yeah mashed potato and gravy I'm upset
about that yeah oh hell no it tastes
exactly like metal dude gravy I can't do
it sorry we're gonna eat meat flavored
ice cream right now it's not just
flavored there's meat inside our ice
cream look sad
it's kind of weird right II don't get it
oh that's the worst ambitious young to
do Thanksgiving ice cream wow factor 10
11 yeah they went so wild that they like
went off the wild charts you call it all
these ice creams in general we're pretty
Pleasant sweet potato okay tone I'm
gonna throw you in front of a moving
vehicle
lesson learned bring your slap hands
yeah I could use a red sweatpants these
jeans are chafing right now we learned
that Thanksgiving can come in many forms
many many for the best for mr. duck in
for you guys we basically just had a
friendsgiving Edie til next time wait
you slept pants what get it there I
never got it get it get it get it it's
here quick